Érase una vez una Bella princesa dormida
por la maldición de una bruja vengativa.
Todos sabemos cómo termina este cuento,
cuando el apuesto príncipe
consigue llegar hasta la princesa
y con su beso la despierta
y, por supuesto,
la princesa cae inmediatamente
rendida de amor a sus pies.
Bueno los cuentos, cuentos son;
y en las antípodas
de estos relatos imaginarios
encontramos las elaboraciones
de la ciencia.
Los cuentos son el mundo de la fantasía,
y la ciencia es el mundo de los hechos.
Sin embargo, el cuento
de la bella durmiente
se coló inadvertidamente
en la representación científica
de la fecundación sexual:
el óvulo yace inerte,
hasta que el más intrépido y veloz
de los espermatozoides que lo corteja
consigue llegar hasta él el primero,
atraviesa su muro y lo activa
para dar comienzo a una nueva vida.
Esta proyección de ideas culturales
sobre lo masculino y lo femenino,
lo que hizo fue obstaculizar
la investigación sobre los mecanismos
activos que tiene el óvulo
para captar a los espermatozoides
y sobre los procesos de capacitación
que el espermatozoide experimenta
una vez que está ya dentro
del tracto genital femenino.
Hoy en día los óvulos actuales,
lo mismo que las más modernas
princesas de Disney,
ya tienen iniciativa propia
y además están bien despiertos.
La ciencia nos proporciona el conocimiento
más fiable que tenemos,
que los humanos hemos desarrollado,
sobre el mundo que habitamos.
Pero la ciencia lo que no puede hacer
es ofrecer verdades
que sean simples e inapelables.
Un buen ejemplo de esto
lo proporciona la primatología.
Descubrir las vidas y los mundos de estos
parientes cercanos nuestros:
los orangutanes, los babuinos,
los bonobos, los chimpancés,
es una tarea absolutamente fascinante,
pero descubrir su mundo nunca
fue únicamente esto.
Porque a menudo lo que se buscaba
al estudiar a los primates,
era encontrar claves para entender el
comportamiento de los primeros homínidos,
un patrón primate que nos ayudara
a conocernos mejor a nosotros mismos;
y por eso Louis Leakey
el famoso paleoantropólogo,
a mediados del siglo XX, promovió
la investigación en primatología.
Leakey pensaba además que las mujeres
íbamos a ser mejores primatólogas
porque tenemos mayor capacidad
para la empatía.
Bueno, no sé si Leakey tenía
o no razón con esto.
Pero las mujeres que él reclutó:
Jane Goodall, Biruté Galdikas, Dian Fossey
con su ejemplo, narrado a través
de documentales de National Geographic,
se convirtieron en modelos
y sirvieron como ejemplo
para que en muchas jóvenes
se despertara en ellas
la vocación por la primatología
y siguieran sus pasos.
Por eso también la primatología
es una ciencia muy peculiar,
porque en ella encontramos muchas mujeres,
más que en otras disciplinas científicas
en las que a veces es muy difícil pensar
en grandes científicas, mujeres relevantes
más allá de la ubicua Marie Curie.
Cuando van a las selvas, las sabanas,
a las montañas, los bosques
a observar a los primates,
la imagen que teníamos acerca
de estos parientes nuestros
se parecía mucho a la de los personajes
estereotipados de los cuentos.
Los machos eran Tarzanes que
conseguían comida para el grupo,
defenderlos de los ataques externos
y competían entre ellos
por los favores de las hembras.
Y las hembras, eran criaturas maternales
que estaban dedicadas a la crianza
y disponibles sexualmente para los machos.
Cuando van a las selvas y a las sabanas,
lo que nos ofrecen
es una imagen mucho más compleja
de las hembras, de los machos,
y de las relaciones entre ellos,
que los estereotipos
de príncipes valientes
y princesas desvalidas de los cuentos;
y al volver más compleja la imagen
que tenemos de los primates,
lo que ocurre también
es que va perdiendo cada vez más sentido
la idea de mirarnos en ellos
como en un espejo.
Porque ahora cada individuo,
cada especie primate,
incluida la especie humana,
es única y tiene valor propio.
Jane Gooddall no solo nos descubrió
que los chimpancés como especie
eran capaces de usar instrumentos,
como piedras,
para abrir frutos secos
o ramitas para meterlas en un termitero
y comerse las termitas, o que eran
capaces de transmitir cultura.
También desveló que los comportamientos
agresivos de los machos
no significaban realmente que
ellos fueran los que mandaran
porque por ejemplo la chimpancé Flo
de un modo mucho más sutil,
era capaz de ocupar un papel relevante
en la organización social del grupo
y además transmitía a sus hijas
ese alto estatus
que ella tenía en la sociedad de Gombe.
Jane Goodall fue capaz de ver
lo que otros no habían visto antes
porque entendió que cada miembro del grupo
era un individuo interesante por sí mismo,
que las hembras no eran un recurso más
en unas sociedades
dirigidas por los machos.
Además, al extender en el tiempo
el trabajo de campo,
la propia Goodall y las sucesoras,
las primatólogas que trabajaron con ella,
nos ofrecieron una descripción
muchísimo más acertada
del comportamiento de las hembras.
Las hembras ahora cazaban,
buscaban activamente parejas sexuales,
luchaban por mantener sus jerarquías
dentro del grupo,
hasta eran capaces de cometer infanticidio
con las crías de otras hembras.
Cuando solamente miramos
lo que salta a la vista,
a menudo podemos estar perdiéndonos
lo realmente interesante.
Esto fue lo que les ocurrió
a los primeros primatólogos
cuando fueron a las sabanas
a observar a los babuinos:
lo que vieron en primer plano
fueron las peleas
y las reyertas de los machos
y entonces en el mundo de la guerra fría,
ellos elaboraron una narrativa
de acuerdo con la cual,
las vidas de los babuinos dependían
de la estructura jerárquica de sus machos.
Estos machos eran individuos
terriblemente agresivos,
que competían entre ellos
fieramente por las hembras,
sin embargo, eran capaces de comportarse
como una tropa muy bien disciplinada
cuando se trataba de proteger al grupo
de un ataque de un enemigo externo.
Pero cuando la primatóloga
Thelma Rowell fue a la sabana
lo que vio tenía muy poco que ver
con esta imagen militarizada.
Ella vio que los machos
no eran tan agresivos,
que las hembras no estaban sentadas
esperando que llegara su príncipe azul,
que eran las relaciones entre ellas
las que realmente estructuraban
la organización del grupo,
y que además estaban súper ocupadas
consiguiendo comida para sus retoños,
o cultivando las amistades que les iban
a ser más favorables
para ayudar a su prole en el futuro.
El modelo militar de los babuinos
fue poco a poco desmontándose,
y otras primatólogas como Jean Altmann,
Shirley Strum, Barbara Smuts,
también contribuyeron a desmontar
ideas muy arraigadas.
Por ejemplo, la idea de que
los machos dominantes
tienen un acceso prioritario a las hembras
y por tanto, hay más crías del grupo
que son hijas suyas.
Ellas lo que nos descubrieron
es que el macho más fanfarrón
no era realmente el que más ligaba,
y que las hembras apreciaban muchísimo
la cualidad de la discreción
a la hora de elegir con quien aparearse.
Montar esta nueva imagen de los babuinos
requería mirar en segundo plano,
lo que ocurría más allá
de las ruidosas reyertas de los machos.
Esto Jean Altmann lo hizo elaborando
protocolos sistemáticos de observación,
que garantizaran, que cada individuo
y miembro de grupo iba a ser observado
y no solamente los que fueran más ruidosos
o llamaran más la atención.
Precisamente la vida sexual de las
primates es un grandísimo ejemplo
de la fuerza que tienen las creencias
para dirigir nuestras observaciones
y la interpretación de las mismas.
Durante mucho tiempo la idea tradicional
era que la iniciativa sexual
era una cuestión únicamente de los machos
y se dudaba, se debatía sobre si
las hembras de los primates
disfrutaban con el sexo
y si tenían incluso orgasmos;
cuando nunca se discutió acerca
de si los machos tenían orgasmos.
Pero el trabajo de Amy Parish
con los bonobos,
o el trabajo de Sarah Hrdy
con los langures,
nos descubre que las
hembras son individuos
que buscan activamente el sexo,
que además para ellas el sexo
no es solamente importante
por su papel en la reproducción.
Según Sarah Hrdy el sexo para las primates
es también placer y estrategia.
Sarah Hrdy sostiene que el disfrute,
que el orgasmo que les provoca
a las hembras de los primates
las incentiva a tener relaciones
con muchos machos.
La ventaja que esto tiene
es la de preservar a sus crías,
porque a menudo los machos lo que hacen
es matar a las crías que no son suyas
para provocar que las hembras
que están amamantando
entren de nuevo en celo.
De este modo las crían se mantenían
de algún modo a salvo.
Esta imagen de las primates como
individuos que son activos sexualmente
contrasta terriblemente con la imagen
que habíamos tenido tradicionalmente
acerca de por qué las hembras
humanas tenemos orgasmos.
Lo que se decía tradicionalmente
es que las hembras humanas
tenemos orgasmos
porque esto refuerza el vínculo
monógamo de la pareja.
De tal modo, las mujeres ofrecemos
a los hombres acceso ilimitado al sexo
y ellos a cambio nos proporcionan,
nos ayudan a cuidar de nuestras hijas.
Entonces Sarah Hrdy lo que hace es
darle la vuelta a este relato tradicional,
y las hembras que eran pasivas,
que eran fieles,
convertirlas en hembras asertivas
y promiscuas.
Lo que creemos que somos
y cómo creemos que debemos ser,
en estos relatos de adaptación,
aparece de algún modo ligado
por la fuerza que tiene la evolución
para definirnos.
Estas transformaciones que
las primatólogas introdujeron
en los métodos y teorías científicas,
nos demuestran que el punto de vista
y la perspectiva es realmente importante.
Ellas con su perspectiva parcial,
lo que hacen es mostrarnos
que la perspectiva dominante
que había sido la masculina,
es también una perspectiva parcial.
Esto ocurre también por ejemplo
en la paleoantropología,
donde durante mucho tiempo
la hipótesis dominante
fue la del "hombre cazador":
la idea de que los humanos
somos lo que somos
porque los hombres del pasado iban a cazar
y por eso hemos desarrollado
el lenguaje, el uso de instrumentos,
el bipedismo incluso.
Adrienne Zihlman, Nancy Tanner,
Sally Slocum,
ellas muestran el sesgo de la
hipótesis del hombre cazador
proponiendo la hipótesis
de la mujer recolectora.
Dicen: no, no somos lo que somos porque
los hombres del pasado fueran a cazar,
somos lo que somos porque las mujeres
del pasado criaban y recolectaban.
Esta teoría estaba bien respaldada
por la evidencia empírica,
pero no fue en lo absoluto aceptada
por la comunidad científica,
porque su evidente parcialidad
era demasiado obvia.
Pero lo que hizo esta evidente
parcialidad fue poner de manifiesto
que la perspectiva
que había sido dominante
era también una perspectiva parcial,
pero una parcialidad que había
estado oculta e invisibilizada.
En arqueología, psicología,
antropología, sociología,
en todas estas disciplinas
encontramos ejemplos
a través de los cuales
las científicas nos demuestran
que los estereotipos de género
tienen una grandísima fuerza para definir
aquello que aceptamos como verdadero.
Y también hay otras disciplinas,
como la medicina,
en las que se muestra
esta ceguera de género
La idea de que el varón es el individuo
universal de la especie humana,
obstaculizó durante mucho tiempo
la investigación sobre las peculiaridades
de la enfermedad cardiovascular
en las mujeres,
excluidas de los ensayos clínicos
porque somos sujetos inestables;
todo el conocimiento sobre el diagnóstico
y tratamiento de la enfermedad coronaria,
se montó sobre datos
obtenidos de los varones.
Cuando la epidemiología lo que nos dice
es que la enfermedad coronaria
es una causa muy importante
de muerte en las mujeres...
aunque quizás sería más adecuado decir
que la causa de muerte de muchas de éstas
fue más bien la ignorancia acerca
de la sintomatología específica,
acerca de los factores de riesgo,
o acerca de la eficacia y la seguridad
de los medicamentos
en su tratamiento con las mujeres.
En definitiva, lo que se decide ignorar
es tan importante como lo que se decide
conocer en la ciencia.
Y estas decisiones los científicos
y las científicas las toman condicionados
por sus propias situaciones parciales,
que condicionan las preguntas
que se formulan,
los métodos que se utilizan,
los datos que se consideran relevantes,
y las preguntas que son aceptables
y que son aceptadas.
Tendemos a ver y a escuchar aquello
que mejor encaja con lo que creemos saber
o con lo que de hecho sabemos.
Y por eso, estos ejemplos
lo que nos demuestran
es que la perspectiva y el punto
de vista es muy importante.
De todos modos, la perspectiva
de las mujeres no es más objetiva
que la perspectiva de los hombres,
pero si contribuye a una mayor objetividad
al poner de manifiesto aquello
que había estado oculto
que es en este caso
que el punto de vista masculino
es un punto de vista parcial.
Quizá, el valor más importante
para la objetividad científica
sea el de la pluralidad.
Porque una ciencia más plural,
es una ciencia que está mejor preparada
para identificar aquellos puntos ciegos,
provocados por una única perspectiva
parcial dominante.
Una ciencia más plural entonces,
será una ciencia más robusta;
porque como decía Richard Levins:
"Las verdades que aceptamos
son la intersección
de mentiras independientes".
(Aplausos)